so we're looking at this we're
introducing this idea called the
binomial theorem okay
now when you see the word fear once of
it a theorem is like the gold standard
this is something we have proven to be
true and not just is it true but it's
true in general sense it's like kind of
always true so when you say okay theorem
like st. Pythagoras noon Pythagoras
theorem applies to everyone I go
triangle that exists okay the binomial
theorem applies to all and as the name
suggests the vc4 binomials now you may
have heard the phrase and I hope that a
lot of you got a bit of exposure to that
at the end of lossy I'm not expecting
you to know what that polynomial just
means well poly poly means many so for
example polygons many angled polystyrene
many molecules of the same at all strung
together that's the weight class these
ah polynomial many and this is a bit
tricky but essentially for our intents
and purposes it means terms do you
remember why the beginning of year we're
talking about algebra we said there are
expressions equations coefficients terms
are just like you execute fine x to the
7 those are terms and Apollinaire who
has lots of how many just binomial have
two only two you're like what the step
backwards isn't that we weren't in
polynomials before well believe me we'll
get there binomials have plenty of
things up their sleeves so as a mutant a
typical polynomial would be something
like sorry binomial rather will be
something like X plus 1 this is a
binomial it's got two toes I can see
that they're clearly different
there's no way to collect them to get
unless you know what X is you're not
collecting anymore you're evaluating
so this is a binomial okay the binomial
theorem has to do with what
when you take this thing and you raise
it to a power okay
particularly integer powers so let's
begin with the first one the first power
that we can think of seems to be trivial
but it's zero okay
mathematicians like to start coding from
zero a lot of time is one of them now
when you raise anything to the power of
0 1 to the power of 0 15 to the power 0
negative Pilar pairs Europe what do you
get you get one every single time no
exceptions
ok so not much interesting is happening
at the minute let's have a look at what
happens when we increase the powers if I
go to the next one and remember I'm
thinking integers so the next one is
just one you're like wow this really is
your little math isn't it ok X plus 1
again not much interesting is happening
just yet here's where it's sort of
begins to take off and we've looked at
some of these back under our previous
topic right we know by definition we
know this pretty well this is just a
perfect square and last time we were
looking at cubic identities so we should
know this one reasonably well
can anyone recite it now just pause for
a second
if you can't recite it that is fine by
the end of this topic you will be able
to we can actually do a little bit of
trickery here to take advantage of the
work we've already done do you agree
that this is just this times this do you
agree ok so I'm just gonna do my pairing
up of all my terms
I'm gonna take everything in here and
I'm gonna multiply it by X then I'm
gonna take everything here and I'm gonna
multiply it by 1 and then I'll just take
the sum it's all I need to do so we'll
multiply everything by XS that would
give me X cubed plus 2x squared plus X
right so there's x times that and then I
have to add on plus 1 of this now for
reasons that will become clear in a
second I hope I'm gonna put this on the
next one
I'm gonna put the x squared here and the
2x here and the one there don't tell me
why I delete it this way I'm trying to
identify the like terms right do you see
those okay
yeah that's the coal and iron minute now
sorry X cubes you can see there are
three X Squared's this three x's and
then there's a one-pager now you're like
alright five we got there I'll do this
one
one water and because of this technique
that I've just developed which is that
if I know what this one is the previous
one I just didn't do the same thing
again I'll multiply every term by X then
I'll both why every term by one and I'll
just add those up that's not difficult
so let's have a go you get X to the 4/3
X cubed yes thank you
okay you see the way I did it how I did
this structure here it's not just like a
stream of unrelated symbols you see I
told you we get to the polynomials and
now I'm going to line up all of the like
terms so I've got a single one of these
okay so I could make you do the next one
but I think that's enough to make the
point what are we looking at here
I particularly want you to pay attention
and I pointed this now back when really
looking cubic identities when we look at
the coefficients in fact if you've got
another color there
let's highlight them here it's just a
one nothing much happening but already
here we have something interesting there
are two coefficients you I haven't
written one of them because you guys
seem to like you don't need to say a
single X you say X but there is indeed a
coefficient of one hiding it in the same
way it's always going to be the
coefficient of one in fact like that and
you can see this is pattern this is he
betrayed you notice 1 2 1 1 3 3 1 and
then the last one we did was 1 4 6 4 1
right so that's weird
I'm going to point out something else
that's we've I asked you to look at the
coefficients now I want you to look at
each one of these lines now how much
should you add their coefficients each
time for each individual one human being
what's the sum of the coefficients ever
give some of the coefficients some of
the coefficients what some of the
coefficients
huh
so there's something going on to you
there's something weird going on and
hopefully some cogs are turning and
you're recognizing actually these
numbers are not just sort of
coincidentally coming up the next one's
going to be 1 5 10 10 5 1 because these
coefficients may recognize as their
numbers bit of PR in this guy okay so
this of course is suppose triangle okay
and you can see up in our top rows there
and yes there is a row 0 you can see the
coefficients that we have just generated
right there's the x squared plus 2x plus
1 there's an X cubed plus 2x squared
plus 3x plus 1 and so on now you're
going to make your own passwords
triangle in a minute but I just want to
point out this is weird right I've
already just noticed that every row of
Pascal's triangle adds up to 1 2 4 8 16
they're not just multiples of 2 their
powers of 2 do you notice that because
this don't isn't this is 2 to the 0 0 0
this is to the 1 this is 2 squared and
you get the idea that's weird that's
weird right I'm this more winners
happening in Pascal's triangle I'm going
to and I want you to think I'll just
have a look where the even numbers in
it's don't say anything there's lots of
them obviously I just want you to look
at where all the even numbers are
can you see where they are it's been
hard where you just trying to look at it
and just see it's all sort of giving you
a bit of hand
here are all the even numbers let me
turn off the laptop a bit clearer for
you
can you see them in blue I know that Jim
you see it do you notice is kind of a
weed structure to where the even numbers
are like wow then there's this kind of
triangular thing and then there's like
more triangles happening
jung-hee no it's not just the even
numbers think about where couple look at
it again figure out where the multiples
of three are can you see some multiples
of three do you see in there there are
the multiples of three there are the
multiples of four there the multiples of
five I don't like to say this very much
but if there's any black beauty of magic
in mathematics this has to be it
okay because can anyone tell me to make
all these numbers where do they come
from they didn't come from taller than
yours where they come from
like for example one to one where do you
just magic those numbers from Eric 121
uses the square of 11 however
interestingly that comes from this is
because the square of 11 is of course 10
plus 1 here that yes so it's really 10
squared plus 2 times 10 plus 1 that's
the one to one the unnoticeable but
there's actually much simpler rule okay
but we can't square 11 that's become
loose okay I may be kind of is a long
time ago
do you can try to a 1 you just add
together the numbers that are on the
previous word do you recognize that
so these two you got one this is going
down the sides all the time but the two
comes from one plus one picking on the
red number is 36 for instance that comes
from 8 plus 28 okay so all you need to
know to make Pascal's triangle and you
will be make a pass which make one
second is just adding numbers it's just
adding numbers that's all that
constructs this and yet somehow
number one you got these reader looking
patterns number two what on earth does
this have to do with anything
this is polynomials binomials and how
they expand
why should this have anything to do with
these and that is a cool mystery in this
course that we will solve okay but not
quite yet